subverting fan expectations is something
that that i'm going to be hitting on a
little bit later in the show too when i
talk about my
scene but how it seems like you had a
strong reaction
to jaclyn highlighting broom kid as one
of the home runs
that josh hamilton let me make sure i
set it up though this is the very end
scene
one of the little kids that's basically
been beaten up he's one of the like
fixing the the casino greyhound
racetrack things
and you know he just walks out he makes
a little motion and you can see that the
broom jumps into his hand rather than
him picking it up
and then he just stands there with his
resistance ring
looking up into the stars saying i got
necks
any of us could be broomkin any of us
i lived for that i lived for that moment
it it democ
added democracy to the force which i
think it needed hal
you can't summon a broom with the force
why well
i mean i am i'm not a jedi nor am i a
sith
i'm um i'm a muggle
uh to mix metaphors here but
i found i like the sentiment
broom kid but again in execution i
found it cloying i found it totally
sappy
and here's what i here's my
interpretation of broom kid
star wars babies they're gonna use the
force and gonna be jedis
star wars babies it's the next
generation
setting up movies star wars babies i'm
doing the muppet baby theme song but
singing about star wars
and scene it's a great i found it
babies theme song and muppet baby that's
a great theme song
the best 22 minutes of television
history is the muppet baby star wars
episode but i digress hell
um yeah i i just i i found it
um clawing pandering and yeah i didn't i
didn't like it that much
also but i appreciate what uh jacqueline
was saying
about ryan johnson doing his star wars
movie
the same way that everyone knows
ryan is spelled r-y-a-n and he spells it
r-i-a-n that's he
some people say star wars films should
be made this way and he's like no but
just how i spell my name
all fakakta i'm going to make this movie
the way i wants to make it
ryan johnson in standup comedy terms is
the comedian who is going to go on stage
and is going to make all of the comics
in the back of the room laugh
and if the audience that is there
happens to enjoy the show
great but it's not necessarily for you
he doesn't take it as far
mitch hedberg he's he is he is a hedberg
he's a patrice o'neill he's not
so far that he's andy kaufman where he's
just trying to alienate
and and get a rise out of them
regardless but
he made a movie where it challenged what
the audience thought they knew about
star wars